clover is a point of sale device company
we are the operating system for small to
medium businesses that means we make it
easy for coffee shops for restaurants
for retail shops to take payments run
their business and deliver happiness to
their customers
clover's devops philosophy is really
around self-service for our engineering
teams we want to make it as easy as
possible for all the amazing engineers
and product managers that we have to
deliver value to our customers
as fast as possible and with the highest
quality as possible like many companies
we were encountering problems of scale
the way we solved that problem is by
adopting more of a devops first
philosophy we empowered our engineering
teams
to build deploy and run their code and
provide the tool and support they need
to do that effectively and by doing that
we remove a lot of the bottlenecks in
our process which means we get code to
production faster which means we get
value to our customers faster and they
can continue to run their business in
the way that they need to in the
changing environment that we're in what
we hope to accomplish by changing our
technology landscape is to make sure
that we can adapt to the changing
environment that our customers in
we are a company with hundreds of
engineers around the world
millions of merchants and billions of
dollars that flow through our platform
in a given year
that means what we do has to be well
orchestrated well planned and well
thought out
so that we do it safely and so our
customers don't see any ill effects one
of the great things about working with
google on our devops transformation has
been able to utilize the experience and
frankly the definition of what a lot of
this is that came through google itself
we were
early in our journey and one of the
challenges that we had was educating our
entire set of engineers and all of our
teams on what this devops transition and
sre transition means not for them as
individuals
google literally wrote the book on sre
but the google support allowed us to
bring in google sres and google devops
experts to train the rest of our teams
and that meant that we could accomplish
a lot more a lot faster having gone
through this it makes me very grateful
for the people that i have around me
uh specifically i'd love to thank all
the engineers at clover for going
through this transition with us all the
product managers all of our customers
most importantly all the people that are
really living and breathing this the
people who are putting in the hours
doing documentation the people who are
writing code and making changes and
going above and beyond what the normal
jobs are just because they believe in
what we're doing and they know this is
the best path forward for us it's not a
simple thing and it takes a lot of
effort and i'm very grateful for for
everyone who's helped out with that